est ce que vous pensez de jacques chirac
je le trouve très dynamique très décidés
et pour ma part je le trouve un
personnage très utile
[Musique]
le trouvez vous
le trouvez-vous sérieux bien sûr
autoritaire il le faut efficace
suis pas assez la politique pour le dire
mais je le pense chaleureux
oui à sa façon intelligente très
vous donne-t-il confiance bien sûr c'est
un endroit zoo celui-là qui
est ce que vous le croyez sérieux à non
pas sérieux du tout photo maguy promet
toujours ide en arrière par ces lieux
autoritaire ah oui autoritaire et
efficace ah non pas du tout chaleureux à
y sol malien j'ai même pas confiance en
lui et rien intelligent à tête
intelligente issaoui sûrement efficace
moi je crois sur lang efficace oui
intelligente entre est présente
3 qui sort de l'ena intelligent oui sur
certains trucs
oui
j'ai confiance on se rend compte qu'un
certain nombre de gens sont influencés
par leurs idées politiques
selon ce qu'ils pensent de même vous
êtes ou tout bien ou tout mal mais en
général on vous reconnaît trois qualités
vous êtes efficace intelligent vous
donner confiance
voici d'autres témoignages plus précis
ce n'est pas un idéologue mais c'est un
défenseur musclée du capitalisme libéral
c'est l'euro car de la majorité
présidentielle il n'ya pas déperditions
d'énergie chez lui on n'imagine pas par
exemple chirac l'homme privé arrêtant
son si ce qu'on entre en action pendant
un an pour écrire un roman on ne les
imagine pas non plus pour les mini selon
sur le tas coup dans une action à
considérer apparemment étrangères
ressemble à la politique il s'est fixé
alors je crois que ce cette faculté de
se récupérer constamment de ne pas
paraître disperser et sûrement un
élément du du mécanisme de confiance que
qu'il peut inspirer
il a su garder a un caractère très jeune
ce qui ce qu'il a pu surprendre
peut-être au niveau niveau
gouvernemental où il est c'est à dire
qu'il je souhaiterais personnellement
que de nombreux sportifs français et sa
façon de voir les choses son esprit
presque compétitif si vous voulez c'est
vraiment un battant extraordinaire et il
a toutes les qualités psychique requises
pour faire un très grand champion
ambitieux bien sûr arriviste et
l'évidence je dirais que tout le monde
le reconnaît ou à peu près le jacques
chirac eux développent à ce propos un
talent extraordinaire il suffit de voir
la manière c'est vrai qu'il y était un
peu contraint à l'époque car si chaban
gagné lui qui avait précipité sa chute
perdre et pour le coup sa place et son
avenir politique
mais la manière dont il a retiré le
tapis sous les pieds du pauvre chaban
dont il a ensuite mater lui dr en colère
et enfin dont il a fait boire la lie aux
barons cela était une
démonstration de ses qualités mises au
service de son ambition
c'est un humaniste très concret et
réalisateur quand il s'attache à un
dossier et dieu sait s'il en a brassé
des dossiers il ne lâche que quand nous
avons abouti à une solution même si
celle ci est partielle de toute façon
chaque fois qu'il ya débat il faut que
ça débouche sur du concret je crois
qu'ils cherchent à être être gentil ce
qui est sans doute une image très
différente de l'image qu'on a de lui
vers l'extérieur qui êtes-vous
réellement nous allons maintenant tenter
de vous connaître lui
vous êtes né à paris le 29 novembre 1932
mais votre véritable maison familiale
est situé à sainte féréole entre limoges
et brive
c'est au corp aesc sont vos racines vos
deux grands-pères furent instituteur
dans la région votre père lui change à
deux vitesses et réussi une véritable
mutation sociale commençant comme
modeste employé de banque
il devint directeur d'une des sociétés
du groupe potez pour recueillir des
échos de votre enfance c'est donc à
sainte féréole que nous sommes allés
vous avez connu jacques chirac presque
avant qu'il soit n'est pas parce que oui
c'est vrai 9 10 mois qu'il avait vous
êtes une petite vie et vous aviez sur
vos genoux
le bébé de la voisine ce sera exactement
comment était-il petit garçon il était
un très beau bilan très belle enfant il
était un petit garçon souriant pas très
sage non plutôt dissiper turbulent mais
très affectueux et il conduisait les
bêtes et il était tout heureux et
surtout de passer devant les vaches
attelées alors là de conduire la
charrette
c'est ça qui l'aimé beaucoup il prenait
toujours le bâton à mon père pour moi
la mer c'était une amie intime et oui
j'étais comme un gosse coin c'est quand
même extraordinaire de voir son petit
fils qui est premier ministre
savamment le verrai quelle joie monsieur
pas voulu il avait un bon père aussi un
brave homme
[Musique]
mais nous sommes en 1940 la société
potez ou travail votre père replie ses
bureaux au rez yole non loin de toulon
c'est là que vous passerez les années de
guerre de 40 à 45
c'est à dire évident avec l'âge
de 12 ans environ de 7 ans à 12 ans 7 à
12 ans bon se retrouver sur la place on
s'amusait dans les tennis qui était à ce
moment là un terrain vague et tous vos
jeux se situait là à peu près entre ce
promontoire la plage et la place au
rouge et pas du real
c'était au fond une espèce de petit
paradis pour les enfants bien sûr
j'apprécie sa mère la place jacques
roujas qui vous pouvez pas vous
certifier la fin nous tout le monde
l'apprécié
en fait il a passé son certificat
d'études ici oui wayolle n'en était sage
dans l'assam l'intéressé sages ont coupé
après des fils de téléphone des albères
ah oui ça souvent où est la main ou avec
un ciseau des ciseaux ont coupé les fils
ça c'était souvent à chirac faisait ça
file des allemands souvent que moi
reçoit cette époque laisser passer des
vêtements c'est grave ça a été le
sabordage de la flotte
on s'est partagé la photo tout leur dire
on a envoyé les fumées 10 6 1
il y avait une ap de fumée guy qui a
duré je sais pas moi peut-être trois
jours quatre jours c'est un jour j'ai
pas dit elle on a loupé tout le ciel on
aurait dit carrément il y avait un nuage
à ses poulains
la guerre terminée votre famille
retourne à paris c'est le lycée hoche à
saint cloud le lycée carlo louis le
grand
vous êtes très bon en maths ou préparer
polytechnique mais ça tourne court vous
virer vers l'institut des sciences
politiques puis ce sera l'école
nationale d'administration vous avalez
les examens vous accumulez les mentions
quel genre d'étude y étiez vous un de
vos professeurs deux de vos anciens
camarades de sciences po nous répond
était-il un étudiant remarquable
différents en avance sur les autres sur
son temps c'était un étudiant
remarquable ce n'était probablement pas
un étudiant différents ils étaient prêts
mais plutôt le le premier entre les eaux
il était parfaitement de ceux qui
réussissent c'est non pas seulement très
au-dessus de la moyenne parce que ça va
sans dire mais très exceptionnellement
au dessus de la moyenne c'était un très
brillant élève de sciences po donc
facile dans ses études tout à fait
facile dans ses études
timide il était timide je ne sais pas ce
qu'il en est même nom et édiles politisé
joué dix ans occupe est il de politique
je ne sais pas je ne crois pas je n'ai
pas gardé le souvenir d'une activité de
quelque sorte que ce soit faux a ajouté
vous savez que rue saint-guillaume tout
au moins à cette époque la politisation
se traduisait dans les nuances beaucoup
plus que dans les clameurs alors ça je
peux vous garantir qu'il ne poussez pas
de clameur certains étudiants faisaient
de la politique mais lui n'était pas
politisée est-ce qu'on sentait déjà
qu'il aurait un destin politique de
confiance messianique
non je n'ai pas de conscience mais
sionisme et à mon point de vue il était
condamné à faire de politique d'abord
parce que sans ces études jusque là lui
avaient donné les moyens ils ont de
comprendre un certain nombre de
problèmes politiques et deuxièmement
raison d'une vitalité doute à fait
extraordinaire il pouvait penser
nécessaire de transcrire un peu cette
formation technocratique dix ans dans un
milieu plus politique
et puis il ya l'aventuré américaine
c'était en 1953 avec un camarade des
sciences politiques vous allez passer
trois mois aux etats-unis dont six
semaines à l'université de harvard
vous partez avec 300 francs ce qui n'est
pas grand chose ils n'étaient pas plus à
l'époque
comment avez vous fait pour vivre mais
nous avons vécu 10 ans par un certain
nombre d' expédient pommade moyens qui
nous ont permis d'obtenir les dollars
nécessaires jacques chirac et moi nous
étions nous étions engagés dans un
restaurant dans lequel nous étions
plongeurs et ensuite lui a été surtout
serveurs et ensuite vous avez fait
d'autres métiers moyennant rétribution
nous avons été chauffeur d'une vieille
dame américaine
bonjour semaine mais il est temps de
faire votre service militaire
sorti sous lieutenant de saumur majeur
de votre promotion vous aurez toutefois
du mal allez vous battre en algérie on
vous affectera successivement au
ministère de l'air à la marine et même à
la garnison de berlin comme interprète
de russes le sort s'acharne pour vous
éloigner d'un combat auquel vous jugé
indigne de ne pas participer vous
sollicitez vous remercier les terres
enfin vous serez affecté au 6e régiment
de chasseurs d'afrique à souk el rba non
loin de la frontière marocaine
vous aviez beaucoup de combats beaucoup
de dents biscam oui c'était en fait une
action qui était amené d'une façon
absolument permanente de jour comme de
nuit c'était une on peut dire que
l'unité était sous tension perpétuelle
est ce qu'il a été décoré
il a été décoré il a été décoré une
citation à l'ordre de la division si je
m'oppose mémoire à votre avis est
illicite et à rester dans l'armée
je crois que oui je crois que oui il
était à cette époque là il était tout
jeune il avait à l'époque trois ans 24
ans il avait tout à fait le gabarit
qu'il fallait pour pour être dans
l'armée c'était un garçon extrêmement
dynamique extrêmement fonceur et qui
avait vraiment un goût de l'action
poussé au plus haut point libéré de
l'armée vous entré au cabinet de georges
pompidou alors premier ministre
la rencontre est d'importance c'est une
sorte de coup de foudre réciproque qui
va bouleverser votre vie très
impressionné par votre ardeur il vous
sur nommera le bulldozer et vous
confiera bien des tâches secrétaire
d'état chargé de l'emploi
vous mènerez en mai 1968 avec les
syndicats
des négociations secrètes qui
prépareront les accords de grenelle puis
vous serez secrétaire d'état aux
finances et trois fois ministres
ministre chargé des relations avec le
parlement
ministre de l'agriculture et ministre de
l'intérieur à 42 ans
c'est une grande expérience de
gouvernement c'est aussi un palmarès
rare l'entrée dans la politique qu'en
1966 nous avait 34 ans c'est l'époque
des jeunes loups de l'ue dr il s'agit
d'arracher l'opposition les
circonscriptions du centre de la france
corrézien vous choisissez ussel en haute
corrèze c'est un pays change ensoleillé
et frais en été rigoureux en hiver on y
pratique l'élevage
il y pleut plus de 200 jours par an vous
avez dans votre circonscription une
région au pittoresque le plateau de
millevaches
vous serez élu de justesse en 1967 au
deuxième tour et facilement au premier
tour en 1968 et en 1973 comment avez
vous fait qui êtes vous encore être
plusieurs de vos électeurs nous en parle
monsieur spinasse ancien ministre et ses
filles oh vous à immédiatement aider
nous lui avons demandé pourquoi j'avais
fait entrer il s'était assis dans ce
fauteuil jarry d'observer un moment seul
trait fin et ce visage tranchant comme
une lame est ce un front très haut
un regard
présent occupé de tout de tout ce qui
était autour de lui
très vif et parfois durs même je le
laissais parler elle rit mais se pose à
ce qu'il est et ce qu'il voulait ce qui
ferait avec tant de netteté dans les
idées de justesse dans l'appréciation
des faits et une assurance si tranquille
dans l'expression de là volonté que j'ai
été vraiment frappé ce jour là bas à la
fois la fermeté du caractère et la
qualité exceptionnelle de l'essai marqué
la première fois nous avons eu nous
étions scène n'est ce pas puisque il
avait convoqué les 5go liste de la
circonscription d'ussel et avec son
gaullisme symboliste inscrit il nous a
convoqués dans une petite pièce est
évidemment nous avons vu arriver un
homme de un fonctionnaire qui s'est
présentée à nous comme futur candidat
dans la circonscription plutôt
modestement presque timide et à ce
moment là nous étions quand même à ces
mois de l'élection et je pense que
n'auront pas été tellement impressionnée
candidature le train du sel chaque
week-end durant des mois et des mois
vous débarquez à 4 heures du matin tout
le samedi tout le dimanche vous visiter
et revisiter chaque village chaque
hameau chaque ferme c'est la solitude du
challenger mais à part cette ténacité
quelles sont les raisons de votre succès
c'est d'abord la simplicité et puis il a
une la faculté de se mettre au niveau de
la personne avec qui il parle on n'a pas
l'impression de parler à quelqu'un de
supérieur quelqu'un qui vous regardent
de haut on parle vraiment d'égal à égal
et il vous écoute
il entend beau problème c'est un ami
qu'on retrouve quand il vient là il nous
considère d'ailleurs comme tel et c'est
ce qui fait d'ailleurs sa force dans la
région c'est que chacun considère comme
son amie et quand il parle il est très
chaleureux au contraire avec nous il
serre la main à tout le monde il demande
des nouvelles de tout le monde de la
famille etc
et ce qui est formidable aussi que ces
grains visage qu'il a vu une fois et
bien six mois après il remet un nom sur
ce visage
il ya une grande demeure oui
certainement une faculté formida dans ce
domaine là la grande valeur de chirac en
corrèze c'est de nous avoir donné le
moyen de nous exprimer et justement
qu'il a cherché à savoir ce que nous
pensions est ce que nous étions il est
très franc mais il accepte très bien
qu'on lui dise autre chose que ce qu'il
a dit d'abord à votre avis est-ce qu'il
aurait réussi aussi bien dans d'autres
circonscriptions de france mais je crois
que de la mieux réussie parce que il ne
faut pas oublier qu'il a conquis une
circonscription qui était entièrement à
gauche politiquement je suis depuis 1929
je suis adhérent au parti socialiste je
suis peut-être encore le seul le seul
qui p 500 à 4 du parti socialiste
pendant qu'anton budget mais pourquoi
alors serait-il votre avis si vous
n'êtes pas d'accord avec lui
politiquement politiquement non mais je
trouve que personnellement c'est un
homme c'est un travailleur c'est un
homme actif qui a su sur le ton de sa
circonscription il a su s'entourer de
jeunes qui ont qui lui ont fait sa force
et j'estime que tout tant que
travailleur pour moi c'est quelqu'un qui
voit là et vous savez il se fait tutoyer
pour beaucoup de jeunes de son ado de
son âge
voyez ça ça rend les gens à l'aise
est-ce que vous avez l'impression que ce
serait un homme de coups durs ah oui
sans aucun doute
sa réussite tient à l'action il exerce
qu'il a exercée sur les maires sur les
conseillers municipaux sur les
conseillers généraux savaient l'action
d'un homme est décuplée par par l'église
bug qui l'année mais dans l'opposition
que pense-t-on de votre action
nous avons interrogé jean pierre cot
député socialiste de savoie selon vous
son action politique est-elle
démocratique democratic ce n'est pas
exactement le terme que j'utilise
serait jacques chirac cherche sans doute
le contact populaire en particulier dans
sa circonscription
je dirai au fond qu'il a retenu du
radicalisme le clientélisme et il
laissait volontiers de rendre service à
tous ces électeurs c'est le métier
politique mais c'est plutôt de la
démagogie
pour ce qui est de la véritable
démocratie je suis moins convaincu
lorsque je venais d'être élu en 1973
j'ai gardé un souvenir assez vif du
débat du budget de l'agriculture jacques
chirac était alors jeune ministre de
l'agriculture et il avait répondu aux
orateurs mais uniquement à ceux de la
majorité
négligeant ceux de l'opposition et donc
le débat démocratique brutale sûrement
l'homme est brutale il est autoritaire
et j'irai plus loin il ne contrôle pas
ses nerfs je l' ai vu lorsqu'il est venu
au conseil régional de lyon et qu'il
avait fait si utilisé l'expression patte
de velours
il avait alors cherché à se montrer sous
l'aspect le plus rassurant
et lorsque mon ami jacques antoine go
député de l'isère avait pris la parole
et avait eu le malheur à ce moment là de
le contrer nous l'avons vu apparaître
avec ce regard froid avec cette violence
et j'avoue que j'ai eu peur dans
l'appartement de l'hôtel matignon que
l'état met à la disposition des premiers
ministres votre femme et vos deux filles
nous en dise plus sur vous est-il facile
à vivre
pas tellement pourquoi parce qu'il est
très exigeant il est très exigeant il
est très exigeant mais il est quand même
très très gentil ou s'habituer aux
personnages et surtout à la fonction
mais il ya neuf ans qu'il est au
gouvernement alors sa femme et ses
enfants eu l'habitude quand même et le
le temps de s'habituer vous trouvez un
peu quelque part que la fonction est
très dévorante
la fonction est très dévorante et
l'emploi du temps est excessivement
chargé du matin jusqu'au soir et le soir
tard m d'ils faire plaisir oui il à me
faire plaisir et il aime que les gens
soient heureux autour de lui il en a
besoin je dirais même il a besoin de
sentir que les gens sont heureux et que
les gens sont de bonne humeur il est
sensible aux atmosphères c'est pas du
tout quelqu'un de froid c'est un être
chaleureux et sensible il se déguise
manifeste par des tas de petites choses
des petits détails
il n'y a pas beaucoup de temps à
accorder sa famille mais tout de même il
ya des petites choses
une petite fleur de temps en temps ou de
petites choses gentilles le luxe pas du
tout c'est quelqu'un de très très simple
mon mari qui aime avant tout la vérité
choses vraies et naturel est-ce qu'il
est le bien manger et les choses
campagnard de la tête de veau par
exemple ilham énormément la tête de veau
ses légendaires en corrèze il
s'intéresse à la cuisine et en plus
sorel à faire il n'a pas le temps ils
feraient des plats en sauce parce qu'il
adore les pleins sauce lessive est par
exemple il avoue se mettre à table
est ce que vous auriez aimé qu'ils
firent notre travail non parce que mon
mari fait pour faire de la politique
c'est incontestablement chez lui une
vocation et par conséquent je suis très
très heureuse qui il réussissait que oui
moi je
j'ai toujours aimé ça et toujours aimé
la politique je me suis toujours
beaucoup intéressé à la vie politique
française et je suis moi même très
modestement mais enfin je suis tout de
même élue une élue municipale de france
puisque je suis conseillère municipale
dans une des communes de la
circonscription de électorale de mon
mari est dans le canton dont il est
conseiller général la commune de sarran
et il sait vers où air du genre plutôt
sévère
c'est tout cela la question de l'école
est plutôt sévère je pense que papa est
assez sévère dans l'ensemble ceci dit
j'ai eu quand même sûrement quelques
problèmes à lui soumettre et on est
arrivés sûrement à des compromis
constructifs donc à partir nous il ya un
compromis ça ça suppose je pense une
certaine indulgence
donc il ya un mélange des deux vous
négociez avec lui j'arrive à négocier
oui donc on y met du sien
est ce que vous auriez aimé que votre
père fasse un autre métier si je puis
dire ou es une autre vocation
je crois qu'il va être peut-être très
désappointé si il apprend ça c'était
personnel j'aime beaucoup la musique
classique
j'aurais aimé avoir un père compositeur
j'aurais bien aimé faire médecine
mais en fait bon ben j'ai complètement
changé d'avis et je porte mon idée sur
papa j'ai regagné mais qu'ils fassent
médecine est-ce que vous avez
l'impression qu'ils voudraient que vous
fassiez de la politique ça c'est
difficile à dire peut-être c'est
possible vous le sentez comme je le sens
un peu oui je sais pas s'il en est
vraiment conscient mais pense
qu'inconsciemment il aimerait il
aimerait peut-être avoir une fille qui
fait de la politique quand même dans sa
lignée quel est votre façon de
travailler
un ministre madame veil et monsieur mono
votre directeur de
binet nous répondent mal à me est ce
facile de travailler avec jacques chirac
oui c'est facile et pour je dirais des
raisons qui ne sont pas du tout celles
qu'on peut penser c'est facile parce que
en définitive il a sion très grande
liberté on influence pas mais il écoute
et il tient compte et ils rapide dans
ses décisions
excessivement rapides et ils facilement
troublée par des événements imprévus
armand très rarement il a une capacité
de réaction capacité de l'absorption si
je puis dire de l'imprévu qui est tout à
fait tout à fait d'étonnantes à mes yeux
parce qu'il de l'exaltation à
l'abattement
apparemment apparemment il donne
l'impression de quelqu'un je ne dirais
pas d'humeur très égal mais qui est
toujours à un niveau 2 de tension élevée
et je n'ai je n'imagine pas il faut
d'abord l'habitude de travailler tout il
a l'habitude quelquefois de ceux décrits
et un peu lui même quand on parle de
problèmes qui ne sont pas de problèmes
politiques comme la musique la culture
il a un sentiment la fâcheuse habitude
de dire que ça m'intéresse prêt qui n'y
connait rien que ça n'est pas vrai mais
c'est une mauvaise habitude
est ce un homme d'imagination certains
en doutent
certains pensent que c'est un homme de
certitudes tranquilles et tenace moi je
crois que dans l'art politique et dans
la vie politique il faut une certaine
forme de l'imagination et cette forme il
l'a sûrement mais il n'a pas au sens de
l'anticonformisme au sens du
dévergondage intellectuelle si je puis
dire
il s'en garde est ce que vous le trouvez
séduisant comme j'ai pas je me suis
jamais posé la question et les conseils
de nice terrienne gouvernement ne donne
pas beaucoup l'occasion de se poser ce
genre de question est-il méthodique
non pas du tout
il a une absence de méthode dans les
choses de la vie courante
il dit souvent qu'il ne sait pas diriger
son cabinet et dit souvent que dans la
vie administrative dans la vie
gouvernementale au sens quotidien une
fois que les choses ont été comprises et
tranches et et qu'on les a comprises
c'est à d'autres à les appliquer si vous
aviez un conseil à lui donner
lequel donneriez-vous peut-être de se
ménager davantage dans l'impression de
vivre intensément d'user intensément son
avis peut-être peut-être un peu trop et
de ne plus fumer
sûrement mais que pensent de vous les
jeunes gaullistes pour nous jeunes
gaullistes chirac représente plusieurs
choses
c'est d'abord ce que j'appellerais un
rassembleur c'est lui qui a permis dans
des moments difficiles de pouvoir garder
au mouvement gaulliste toute sa
plénitude et aux idées gaullistes d'être
représentés c'est aussi un homme
d'avenir d'avenir parce qu'il est jeune
qui l'est déjà énormément d'antécédents
et jusqu'à présent il n'a pas pu montrer
toute sa plénitude et toutes ces idées
selon vous quelles sont ses qualités ses
qualités un dynamisme certain une
volonté tout ce qu'il entreprend arrive
au bout un certain déterminisme ce que
j'appellerais un déterminisme c'est à
dire que tout ce qu'il entreprend c'est
parti d'une ligne générale d'une ligne
directrice
selon certains vous êtes l'image même du
technocrate on est beaucoup trop
politique pour être le technocrate type
je crois que la politique au sens très
très général du terme au sens de
l'avenir de la france et en même temps
du jeu politique pour penser cet avion
la france sont
beaucoup trop important chez lui pour
qu'on puisse le définir comme un
technocrate sûrement c'est un excellent
un excellent élève de l'école nationale
d'administration qui forme de trait dont
un haut fonctionnaire et jacques chirac
en a tous les avantages je dirais en
même temps tous les défauts les
avantages c'est un homme qui s'est
dépouillé rapidement un dossier qui a
une grande force de travail et qui est
capable de saisir l'essentiel dans une
affaire même si la connaît mal c'est le
propre du technocrate
mais le défaut aussi qui est de jouer de
cette fausse compétences car en fin de
compte l'école nationale
d'administration ne donne aucune
compétence particulière
elle ne donne que celle du discours pour
faire illusion en quelque sorte et pour
se saisir des leviers du pouvoir
car nous touchons ici au problème du
monopole exercé par l'école nationale
d'administration sur le pouvoir
politique
songez que outre valéry giscard
d'estaing et jacques chirac jean-pierre
fourcade et l'école nationale
d'administration michel poniatowski
enfin j'en oublie jean pierre soisson et
que dans les cabinets ministériels pour
l'essentiel ce sont des élèves de
l'école nationale d'administration
le problème n'est pas qu'il le soit mais
qu'ils exercent ainsi ce monopole par
une compétence qui est davantage un art
de faire qu'une connaissance véritable
votre pensée politique vous l'avait
révélé dans deux articles de fond
réflexion sur l'action politique
et demain nous en avons extrait les
thèmes principaux
tout d'abord vous réaffirmer la primauté
incontestable de l'homme et de sa
liberté
les hommes sont la seule raison qui
vaille la seule société humaine et celle
qui permet aux hommes de se savoir des
hommes libres puis vous condamner la
bureaucratie la liberté économique et la
liberté sociale suppose que la société
ne soit pas étouffée dans le carcan de
la bureaucratie
l'homme doit être libre dans les moindre
détour de sa vie le bonheur ne sera que
ce que chaque français saura faire de sa
vie ce que la france permettra à chacun
des français de faire de sa vie c'est
cela la liberté c'est cela qu'aucun état
ne peut imposer mais que l'état
totalitaire peut détruire l'état lui
même doit évoluer la politique de
réformes structurelles n'est pas une
ruse pour prolonger l'existence des
structures évoluent elle est la seule
voie de transformation des conditions de
vie de tous dans le respect de la
liberté de chacun
mais cette liberté se gagne il n'y a pas
de liberté s'il n'y a pas de risque
la société que nous voulons et que nous
nous attachons à construire ne saurait
être ce que je nommerais brutalement une
société hôpital dans ce monde difficile
la liberté ne peut être que le synonyme
d'efforts vous condamnez les systèmes il
n'existe pas de déterminisme historique
et surtout pas de déterminisme de la
liberté moins d'un siècle après la mort
de marx les hommes perçoivent que leur
existence historique est une suite de
défi ambiguë et non d'enchaînements
préfabriqués les sociétés humaines ne
sont nullement contrainte par un faux
déterminisme historique d'évoluer vers
des formes de plus en plus intense de
vie collective et vous concluez par un
principe de gouvernement condamnation du
rêve primauté à l'imagination gouverner
dit on c'est prévoir
prévoir et le contraire de rêver prévoir
c'est ne rien oublier
pour pouvoir imaginer tout
[Musique]